- [Voiceover] So in the last
video we started talking
about the system of Jim Crow segregation,
which was a legal form of segregation,
and denial of voting rights
or disenfranchisement,
which characterized the American south
from approximately 1877 to 1954.
Now we finished up by saying that,
with the end of the Civil
War, the system of slavery,
which had been the economic
and political system
which characterized all of the south
for the 200 plus years
before the Civil War,
and I finished up by saying,
now that the Civil War has
outlawed slavery in 1865,
what is the south going to
look like without slavery?
So in this video, I want to really dial-in
in this period after the Civil
War known as Reconstruction.
Now I don't have room here to go into
a great deal of detail
about the Civil War,
we'll make many more videos
about that in the future,
but what I do think is important
to note about the Civil War,
is that for the United States of America,
often called the north in the Civil War,
even though the Civil War
really didn't start out
as a war to end slavery,
by the end of the Civil War
it had really become a war to end slavery,
as northern armies became in effect
armies of liberation in the south.
In 1863 Abraham Lincoln issued
the Emancipation Proclamation,
which ended slavery
in all states that were rebelling
against the United States,
and in 1865 the government ratified
the 13th Amendment to the Constitution,
which outlawed slavery for good.
But all the 13th Amendment said
was that you couldn't have slavery,
it really didn't say anything about
what race relations between
whites and blacks in the south
would be after the Civil War,
or whether not being a slave meant that
an African American person in
the south had the full rights
of citizenship that a
white person would have,
so in the immediate
aftermath of the Civil War,
states in the south began
writing new constitutions
to account for the end of slavery,
but the white leaders in the
south really have no conception
of a world where African
Americans are equal to whites,
and so the new laws that they write
regulating African Americans after the war
are known as the Black
Codes, and these Black Codes
are in many ways slavery
by a different name.
So the Black Codes acknowledged
the end of slavery,
and they give some basic
rights to African Americans
such as the right to marry,
which enslaved people could not legally do
under the system of slavery,
and the right to own property.
But that is pretty much it.
The Black Codes did things
like prevent African Americans
from owning firearms,
from being without a labor contract,
now remember the south is
based on these cash crops
like tobacco and cotton,
and landowners are terrified
that if all of the former
enslaved people leave the south,
they're going to have nobody
to work in their fields,
nobody to harvest these crops,
and their economic system
is going to plummet,
they're already in very bad
shape after the Civil War.
So they say, all African Americans
have to be in a labor contract,
and these labor contracts
were usually very small wages
for quite a bit of labor,
and if they were not in a labor contract
or if they left in the
middle of a year, say,
then they were considered vagrants.
And the most outrageous thing
that these southern governments do is say
that African Americans cannot vote.
Now to people in the north,
who had just fought a four year-long war
where more than half a million
people died, to end slavery,
seeing southern states pass
laws that are pretty much
slavery with another name, was galling.
And so the more radical
Republican elements in Congress,
these are members of
Abraham Lincoln's party,
who are strongly
abolitionist, who are strongly
in favour of civil rights
for African Americans,
and strongly in favor of a
strong central government,
say "OK, this system of
Black Codes is not OK.
"When we said slavery was over,
"we didn't just mean that
you couldn't enslave someone,
"we also meant that African Americans
"had full citizenship
rights in the south."
So to combat the Black Codes,
Congress passes the 14th
Amendment to the Constitution.
And the 14th Amendment says that anyone
who was born in the United States,
regardless of whether or
not they were a slave,
is a full citizen of the United States
eligible for all of the
benefits of citizenship
and equal protection under the law,
so laws must be equal for
whites and for blacks.
And we'll get into what that
means, in the next video.